[Music]
and times have changed news I like that
I'm ready to see what kind of [ __ ]
is going on so [ __ ] I'm gonna be
disappointed if it's not okay
submitted by Philip P Philip please give
us some [ __ ] yeah let's find out
okay
surgery students are struggling to use
their hands because they've spent too
much time watching TV as children what
does that mean what how does that even
wait that's not some [ __ ] I mean
what is that
it's I think it's so much [ __ ] that
we don't even understand how that's
possible
mm-hmm late night at home time surgery
students can't whatever because the TV's
students are struggling to use their
hands because they spent too much time
watching TV as children so they didn't
develop the dexterity and their fingers
and like their hands what does he have
to do with anything
good luck naming this video Jeff holy
[ __ ] what is one called yeah so this
professor in London is arguing that
students have become less competent and
less confident in using their hands
because of their way that they'd spent
their childhood by watching too much TV
instead of sewing or playing an
instrument or do your mining for gold
we're doing woodwork working in coal
mines you talking about brother wrote
this yeah his name is Seamus TV I'm like
no we're the most we have the most
dexterity that we will ever have like
I've been playing video games and
texting for like my hand-eye
coordination [ __ ] sharp dose of that
catch it I think that would be doing
something at me I will catch it really
doesn't have a top I will catch it
before it's me I'm good I'm tell you I
got blindsided and it's basically here
in here yeah well as a professor
Kneebone Roger and me bone so you say
that Hammond is colleagues the
scientific colleagues are concerned
because coven of hundred year olds
because okay yeah because they're saying
that surgery students are having trouble
like you know sewing like they need to
be able to sew someone up when they're
stitching you know stitching that's not
TV they're just not [ __ ] who sews I
said when I was a child I knit and sewed
all my knickers oh yeah before I know
how to sew by hand not with the machine
oh yeah I tried to sew like a hole that
I had in my pants and yeah I used to do
cross stitching for fun oh me too
I used to make Barbie clothes and in my
first business was hand sewing like hair
bows like fabric hair bows like yeah I
was like 13 that's it like big bows
right so you'd be a great surgeon make
bows like those while both yes isn't
this like the responsibility of some
sort of placement test to test your hand
dexterity like I think it's too late to
get into surgery school for them to go
hey you're gonna be a bad surgeon
because of try your child TV well that's
the thing that their reason why they're
speaking out and saying this because
they're trying to get the programming in
schools to be more about like hands on
things and he's saying like you know
having perfect grades aren't gonna make
you a great surgeon when it comes to
actually performing and like doing these
things yeah but when you go into the
medical profession I mean correct me if
I mean you would know this more right if
you wanted to be a doctor but yeah
there's a test in a level that even
tells you
you can and can't be like if you like
isn't it's like before you even go to a
specialized thing just because you want
to be in that specialized thing doesn't
mean that you'll be allowed to do it
yeah in the space in the States bottom
about the UK I could see that like in
the sense of like gaming like I know a
lot of kids now that want to be like
famous streamers and gamers but they
don't have the dexterity to be good at
some of these like shooting games and
stuff so they won't be as big no matter
how much they try they won't be as big
as some people because they just have
like above human abilities you know in
certain categories and so that's why is
there some students aren't even good
they just have great tits exactly great
set of tits or they talk the right
amount of [ __ ] to whoever they're
playing that's true so funny like a
friend of mine works at a what we call
like an animation studio and then he was
telling me that all the guys there they
all watch streaming stuff right and I
was like and I was like well out of all
the streaming stuff that they watch how
many of them are guys they're like none
exactly I was watching all girls yeah I
was like every single one Oh in there
and then and then dude I read this funny
[ __ ] post on one of the crypto boards
where it was like a guy who had a
Bitcoin he was trying to he was trying
to get $10,000 worth of Bitcoin because
he wanted to surprise his favorite
Twitter streamer with a $10,000 donation
and then she would notice him and then
she would try to reach out to him to
thank him and then he could meet her and
then they could fall in love I'm not
even kidding you then that's a very real
thing I remember seeing this one poster
like this this this twitch streamers she
didn't tell anyone that she was
basically married for like a few years
and like this one of her like top
donators it's like gave all this money
and then when this thing came out and
said she was married he was like how
could you I've given you so much money
so much my time I moderate your channel
every day and you're married he's
working an angle he wasn't a nice guy
calm the whole time
bald figure what a shot
curr hey Batman's with celebrities too
or fans like that they will never in
their lives meet these celebrities
they'll get so upset when they end up
dating somebody question does twitch
allow for nudity no you can't even show
fee you give an bro special feet you
can't show feet but there's a lot of
people to do body painting now and on
god it's just straight-up bull on titty
and like they'll put pasties on and like
thick cover and then they're like this
is alright that's the free market
working on a problem and I like it
that's who's the person that does that
there's a lot there's an entire category
on twitch for body painting and I just
got type of body painting in which there
you go see it so nudity got banned but
then body painting emerged and they'll
have like don't have like three
different angles like note they'll have
like full screen of like their camera
and then like two side cameras it's like
and now well I have a question and so if
they're doing that right is it possible
that they can get a workaround with that
if they paint a dick like a spaceship
and it goes into her mouth and then if
it's like looks like she's a space
station and then her mouth is the hanger
you just look into all the rolls and
they paint it and they're like this is
this is allowed because I don't pay good
money for that there's a space
demonstration yet cuz why can't pay the
titty
but I can't paint a dick thank you mmm
you know what just the titties way
prettier than a dick though dude why our
titties way more certain in dicks it's
not fair because it's not veiny it's not
like it's just just overly yes because
they're symmetrical yeah like dicks just
look like the predator mouth that comes
inside of a crime just about though
there's also the balls true and also
titties don't really smell as bad as a
penis does no they don't
don't they smell pretty good if dicks
came in pairs whether it be better know
just double intimidation
reddit's snake dude that shit's [ __ ]
extra scary oh there's a guy that said
they had two penises we talked about on
musa long penis Danny prove it uh he
would like [ __ ] two girls he could
spread it that much before some guys can
do the splits yeah doesn't have two sets
of muscles that must be the most tiring
hand job for a girl didn't matter how
big his ball sack is they only has one
ball what would be disappointing
what if he gets hardened so much blood
rushes from his brain he [ __ ] passes
out oh my god I just happens to
something that has a huge dick know what
that's like
all right yeah we have no idea so thanks
a lot whenever I have a boner nothing
happens my head and face fine I get
smarter when I get boners people with
small penises right now passes out
because all the blood rush to his penis
I saw that might happen though I thought
how did he die it sounds like a TLC show
no it wasn't a real-life pick 14 inch
dick life yeah exactly that's like the
guy who [ __ ] his car Chevy commercial
I'm so sick and tired of these
commercial music yeah yeah I'm a real
person this has got a great autumn Auto
Award I don't give a [ __ ] how about you
get the guy who [ __ ] the car to be like
yo I left that car cars that's what I do
everyone knows that [ __ ] the muffler
yeah I know no you [ __ ] the red car he
like would caress it and then he came
out to his dad about how he [ __ ] his
car and how he's a mother yeah it's
great show what if he came out for the
car I'd be like that's a good person to
endorse oh yeah
they're not selling that angle you can
[ __ ] the car but it's still like I
trusted this guy he loves cars more than
this person who knows cargo gets
intimate with vehicles cars I'm here to
tell you that the Prius 2019 because I
couldn't tell you about this the crash
report you know this is the one that
gets me going she's like okay maybe this
is one we can put a brandy this
professor Kneebone he was saying that
students can learn from both magic and
puppetry about performing and that they
can also learn where what that's like
the most convoluted [ __ ] process ever
it's a puppetry so you can be a doctor
one day learn magic what they said about
performing that's about repetition no
man I can't rather than in like a
textiles class he's like let's do
puppetry no he said let's do magic some
[ __ ] illusion with your hand so fast
I mean white why not just take [ __ ]
sewing classes the next thing I was
gonna say is working with lace makers to
see how they do like in the skills of
embroider you should have been the first
animal or how about even just a junior
medical program right like whatever
you're going to prepare for now let's
make it for first graders
okay yeah yeah so this is for kids like
yeah that's right mean like you know
like there's cops right and then if you
really want to be a cop you can be like
a junior high cadet or something you're
still waving a baton you [ __ ] do all
the [ __ ] marching and all that stuff
instead of hey if you want to be a cop
maybe you should go bowling first it's
like what does that to do with anything
just do the junior version of in McGee's
I guess they're also trying to say like
not just for surgery students because
then they're also saying like you know
kids should learn how to make things and
like actually create with their hands
instead of just focusing on memorizing
things in a book and then recruited to
you just gotta know what minecraft is
dude kids are making [ __ ] that when I
was growing up I couldn't even dream
yeah not like what their physical with
can I though they're like but he was
gonna do magic it's not a [ __ ] sound
counselor foreign kids don't make Sam
cows and [ __ ] anymore
true the only time I ever like magic was
if I was on Twitter and it had to be a
black dude that did magic cuz he made it
sound cool he was like no what's up cuz
you look real quick dannis she sounds
dope is [ __ ] out before it was like so
dreamlike hey Ilana see Magic carrot-top
do magic you were like David Blaine wade
through serious yeah I love my job but
he was not David Blaine
is so seriously he does it so my face is
when he does things just cuz he's [ __ ]
impregnating you with this
you try to [ __ ] her what a good thank
you
[Music]